Transcriber: Widad Y
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
مرحلة لماذا أنا؟
يمكن أن تكون هي المرحلة
التي دخلتها وكل إنسان فيكم سيدخلها.
تدخلك مرحلة لماذا أنا؟
في مفترق طريق كبير جدًا:
من الممكن أن يكون أكثره
إما إيجابيًا أو سلبيًا.
قبل خمس سنين، كنت طالبًا
في هذه الجامعة، جامعة بيرزيت.
كنت أجلس في معهد التنمية، وفجأة!
أحسست بألم شديد للغاية بعيني: عيني اليمنى.
الاستاذ بدأ يختفي واللوح اختفى،
واختفى أصحابي تدريجيًا.
في لحظة هذا الغباش والألم،
شعرتُ أنهما من المؤكد بسبب
قلة النوم والعمل ليلًا،
حيث كنتُ مؤمنًا حينها أن ساعتي نوم تكفي،
وربما تكونا زيادة لنكمل يومنا لأننا شباب
فغدًا نشيخ وننام كما يحلو لنا.
وما كنت أعرف أن هذه المقولة ستنطبق عليّ.
قررت عمل فحص، وما عرفتُ أن هذه الفحوصات
ستستمر إلى تسعة أشهر.
هذه الفحوصات المتعبة
التي أنهكتني نفسيًا وجسديًا،
شملت هذه الفحوصات الرنين المغناطيسي
والخُزع والحواس وأعصاب الحواس.
ولن أنسى طيلة حياتي أول مرة
دخلتُ فيها ماكنة الرنين المغناطيسي،
كنتُ أقف هكذا وعيناي إلى فوق،
وممنوع أن أحرك رأسي لا يمينًا ولا شمالًا.
هذا الإنسان الذي كان مفعمًا طاقة وحيوية،
يقف هنا ويجلس ساعة كامة،
يجلس ساعة كاملة حيث ممنوع أن يتحرك،
وكان السؤال الوحيد الذي يتبادر
إلى ذهني، لماذا أنا هنا؟
في تاريخ 30\3\2017،
تم تشخيصي بمرض اسمه
التصلب المتعدد أو ما يمسى MS؛
كان الاسم غريبًا بالنسبة لي ولم أهتم.
لكن عندما سألتني أخواتي اللواتي يدرسن الطب
عما أعاني منه وقلت لهم التصلب المتعدد،
جعلتني دموعهن وأعينهن أن أفهم
أن هناك شيئًا خاطئًا يحصل لي.
جعلتني أفهم أن هناك
شيئًا جديًا خاطئًا يحصل معي.
ذهبت وقمت بأكبر غلطة من الممكن
أن يعملها أي شخص فيكم، استخدمت جوجل،
وسألتُ جوجل، ما هو  التصلب المتعدد؟
وإذا سألت جوجل أنني أعاني من ألم في الرأس،
سيجيبك باقي لك 10 أيام.
أنتم تتخيلون ما هي النتيجة
التي أظهرها لي جوجل.
لكن، بعد ذلك تعلمتُ من خطأي
وفهمتُ ما الذي يعنيه التلصلب المتعدد.
فهمت أن جهاز المناعة الذي من المفروض
أن يحميني، أصبح يهاجمني،
أصبح يهاجم دماغي ونخاعي الشوكي وحواسي،
وجهاز المناعة هو الذي يقرر
متى يهاجم وكم من الوقت يهاجم،
وما هي مدة الفترة إذا كانت طويلة أو قصيرة.
بصراحة، فكرة أنني فقدت القدرة
على التحكم بجسمي كانت مخيفة ومرعبة.
غضبتُ وحزنتُ وأغلقت كل شيء:
لم أعد أستخدم وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وأغلقتُ أجهزة هواتفي وعزلتُ نفسي.
عزلتُ نفسي وناجيتها قائلًا،
لماذا أنا من بين كل البشر؟
ورجعت تذكرت،
ورجعت تذكرت أنني وفي عمر خمس سنوات،
كنتُ أواجه مشاكل في النطق.
كلمتا جزرة وشجرة كانتا من أكبر مشاكلي.
كانت قدرتي على صياغة جملة طويلة
معضلة كبيرة بالنسبة لي.
تعرضت لتنمر كثيرًا من القريب والبعيد.
هذا التنمر الذي كنا نشاهده عبر التلفاز
دون أن نفهم ما الذي تعنية كلمة تنمر.
كنتُ دائمًا أقول لنفسي،
لماذا أتحدث بهذا الشكل؟
لكنني استطعتُ تخطي
هذه الصعوبة وهذا الموقف
بدليل أنني أقف أمامكم وأتحدث.
(تصفيق)
وقررت دخول جامعة بيرزيت وأنا مفعم بالطاقة،
أردت عمل كل شيء وقررت دخول كل شيء،
كان هذا حلمي وكان هذا هدفي.
وما عرفت أنني سأواجه عقبة أخرى بعد سنتين؛
وهي انفصال أهلي،
كان انفصالهما عقبة كبيرة جدًا.
لأنه يعني أنه ينبغي عليّ العمل
لأنفق على نفسي وأوفر أقساط جامعتي،
وفي نفس الوقت أساعد في مصروف البيت.
وهناك موقف من المستحيل أن أنساه،
هذا الموقف عندما استيقظت ذات صباح
ووجدتُ المياه حولي.
(تصفيق وهتاف)
في ليلة شتاء، استيقظت ووجدتُ المياه حولي،
وجدتُ نفسي أطفو على فرشتي في ليلة شتاء.
من المفروض أن يطفوا الناس على البحر،
وأنا أطفو على فرشتي.
كنت أقول لماذا يحدث هذا معي
حتى وصلت إلى تاريخ 30\3\2017،
غبّشت عيناي وغبّش حلمي معهما،
غبّش مستقبلي،
(تصفيق)
غبّش مستقبلي، وكان كل ما بنيته
يتدمر أمام عيوني،
كان ذلك مخيفًا جدًا،
(تصفيق)
فكرة أن عينيّ عبّشت والدكتور يقول لي:
هذا المرض قوي جدًا وسيسيطر على حياتك،
ينبغي أن تغير حياتك لتتناسب مع مرضك.
فكرة أن حياتي تتلاشى
وغباش عينيّ كانت مخيفة جدا،
كانت مخيفة جدًا.
كنت أقول لربي: لماذا أنا من بين كل البشر؟
لماذا أنا يا ربي من بين كل البشر؟
وفجأة،
اكتشفتُ أنني كنتُ طوال حياتي
أسأل السؤال الخاطئ وهو لماذا بدلًا من كيف؟
كيف استطعتُ تخطي مشكلة النطق؟
كيف استطعتُ تخطي مشاكل كثيرة واجهتني؟
ما جعلني أحضر اليوم وأقف أمامك
وأتحدثُ عن مرضي بقوة،
وهناك حديث قوي جدًا يقول:
“إِنَّ الله تعالى إِذا أحبّ عبدًا ابتلاه“.
عرفت أن ربنا اختارني لسبب،
لأنه يعرف أنني قوي كفاية.
صرتُ أتحدى كلّ شخص أعرفه قائلًا،
ربنا اختارني ولم يخترك.
لأنه يعرف أنني قادر،
ولأن ربنا يحبني كثيرًا.
وأعطاني هذا قوة وطاقة
للمضي قدمًا فأنا قادر،
وأن مفترق الطرق الذي دخلته
وأنا صغير حتى لآن،
كان لسبب لأن أصبح أقوى
وأتحدى أي مرض يواجهني.
فماذا فعلت؟ قررت أن أعيش.
ببساطة، توقفت عن تأجيل ما أتمناه.
أردتُ القفز من طائرة،
فقفزتُ 13 ألف قدم، وأنا فوق...
(تصفيق)
وأنا فوق، شعرت كأني ملك الكون،
ورأيتُ كم هي الدنيا صغيرة وأن المرض أصغر.
تم اختياري لتمثيل فلسطين
في مؤتمر في كينيا،
قال لي الطبيب أنه من الخطر
الذهاب  إلى كينيا ومنعني من ذلك،
قلت له أنني لم أحضر لأسأل هل ذهابي
خطر أو لا، جئت لأخبرك أنني ذاهب إلى كينيا.
وذهبت إلى كينيا ومثّلتُ فلسطين.
(تصفيق)
والآن، بعد خمس سنوات،
أود أن أقول للدكتور،
ولكل شخص شكّك في قدراتي،
خضر الذي يقف أمامك
استطاع أن يسيطر على المرض،
خضر الذي أمامك لم يجعل المرض حياته،
بل جزءًا من حياته.
لأنني لأول مرة في حياتي
أعرف معنى كيف بدلًا من لماذا؟
وأظن أنه جاء الوقت
لنعرف معنى كيف بدلًا من لماذا؟
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)